CAT ALLMAN: Hi, I'm Cat Allman
with Google's Open Source
Programs office.
I'm here today with my
colleague, Stephanie Taylor.
Stephanie manages
Google Code-in.
Its our contest for younger
open source developers.
Stephanie, tell us about
Google Code-in.
STEPHANIE TAYLOR: Well, Google
Code-in is a contest that's
held entirely online, that's
global, that is geared towards
13- to 17-year-old
pre-university students--
so generally high school
students--
that are interested in learning
more about open
source software development.
We choose 10 open source
projects that will act as
mentoring organizations, that
create a list of tasks in a
variety of different categories
for the students
work on during a seven
week contest.
And this year the contest begins
on November 18, 2013
and goes until January
6, 2014.
CAT ALLMAN: Fantastic.
Google Code-in, does this is
mean it's only coding?
STEPHANIE TAYLOR: No.
With open source software
projects, there are a variety
of different skill sets
needed to make an open
source project thrive.
So we try to reflect that in
the Google Code-in contest.
So we have coding tasks, of
course, but there are also
documentation tasks, training,
UI, and a few other different
categories that students
can choose from.
CAT ALLMAN: Great.
What kinds of open source
projects participate as
mentoring organizations?
STEPHANIE TAYLOR: Well, on
November 1 is when we're going
to actually announce the 10 open
source projects that will
be acting as the mentoring
organizations for 2013.
But, generally in the past,
we've had disaster relief
software projects, we've had
graphical desktops, we've had
gaming projects, and a variety
of operating systems.
CAT ALLMAN: So all kinds of
things so that there's
different kinds of things
to motivate
students to get involved.
That's great.
STEPHANIE TAYLOR: Exactly.
CAT ALLMAN: So it's a contest,
so there are prizes.
But are there benefits
beyond cool stuff?
STEPHANIE TAYLOR: Definitely.
Now, everyone likes to get a
prize, but it's also really
fun for the students to actually
use the computer
science skills that they've
learned in school or on their
own to actually apply
those skills to real
world software projects.
So they also get to become part
of a community, and being
appreciated for their work and
their ideas is a huge boost
for, generally, these
teenagers.
So it's cool to see your code
actually in a project or to
see the film that you recorded
describing the Open Source
project actually on screen.
CAT ALLMAN: How cool.
How does the contest actually
work, though?
STEPHANIE TAYLOR: So starting
on November 18, students
actually will go to the contest
site-- which is
google-melange.com--
and they can register,
and then they can
start claiming tasks.
There's a huge list of tasks up
there that they can choose
from, and when they find
something that interests them,
they just choose it, and they
start working on it.
And if they have any questions
along the way, there are
mentors that are actually
assigned to each of those
tasks that are there
to help them.
CAT ALLMAN: Fantastic.
Now, I know I was
saying benefits,
but grand prize trip.
STEPHANIE TAYLOR: Yes.
That is a very popular
question.
Everybody likes to hear about
the grand prize trip.
So when students complete one
task, they actually will get a
certificate of completion.
When they complete three tasks,
they get a Google
Code-in t-shirt.
So that's pretty cool.
But we'll also have 20 students
who are going to win
a grand prize trip to
Google's Mountain
View, California campus.
And that will be for themselves
and a parent next
spring for about four nights.
CAT ALLMAN: Oh.
I've been on this trip.
It's pretty fun.
So let's see.
Where can they go for more
information besides the website?
STEPHANIE TAYLOR: We also have
the Google Open Source blog,
and they can join the Google
Code-in discussion list where
they can ask questions, and
other students, mentors and
Google program administrators
will answer their
questions for them.
So, again, November 18 is the
big day when students can
first start claiming tasks
on the contest.
CAT ALLMAN: Fantastic.
We hope this interview spurred
your interest in Google
Code-in, and if you are 13
through 17, a student, and
interested in Open Source
software development, we
really hope you'll come to the
site, learn more about it,
register and participate.
It's a lot of fun.
Thank you so much
for watching.
Have a great day.